try and go out on a on a really high
note do you have any
advice that you'd like to leave the
listeners with um
i think uh my i i'm assuming the
listeners are probably martial artists
so um
almost yeah so um i would say you know
there's those
points in your in your training where
you get frustrated
and you you whatever you want to call it
like you feel like you've hit a plateau
and i remember that
very clearly in the filipino arts and
certainly in the internal arts in
different periods
um where you just feel like you suck
basically and you've been training for
20 years
um and i i always think that's
often like where sometimes people quit
not not if they've been training 20
years but sometimes
they've been training three um and
that's often
when you get to the next level is
when you feel like nothing works or you
don't under even understand
why you're doing it what you're doing um
i think one
chinese writer from the past and she
said something like
when you've entered the maze of doubts
that's when you're going to get better
and that that
if every when everything's going
smoothly and you feel like oh everything
moves good i got the forms i got the
kicks
you're actually well he says very
clearly if you practice your whole life
like that you'll achieve
nothing but if you actually get to the
point where you feel like you're doing
everything
wrong and when you come out the other
side of that that's
then you're then you're making progress
and i think um that's something i'd
leave with everybody because it was a
lesson for me
that that's actually when you go see
your teacher or maybe
you meet another person who says
something to you
in that moment where you think i'm doing
everything wrong and
suddenly it flips and you realize you've
made progress
because when you're making progress
actually
things that felt comfortable don't feel
so comfortable during that
change point